ではではやっていきましょう
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
焼きたらこパスタとかも美味しそうかもしんないっすね
うまい。
実は僕ですね、
いろんな心霊スポットに行って
コックリさんとかもね、こういろいろやってみたんですけども
まあ、僕がなぜこんなに心霊現象を出来るかといいますと、
霊感が無いんですよ
なんでこんな点滅してる？
で、実際に霊を見ないから
やっぱどうしてもね、見るまでちょっと見たいんすよ
どうしても幽霊を見てみたい
そういう現象にあってみたい
非常に危ないのは知ってるんですけど
霊感が無いからちょっとこればかりはどうしようもないんで
１回ね、僕もちょっと痛い目に遭いたいなと思ってるんすよ
たぶん痛い目に遭うまで僕、これやめれないから
楽しいんすよ
感じたいんですよ霊を
霊感とかをね
なので今日はちょっとそういうちょっと心霊現象チックなものをちょっとやってみようかと思いまして
結構ね、多分知ってる人もいると思うんですけどもー
ひとりかくれんぼ
都市伝説なのかな？
やり方が多分あったんですけど
儀式らしいですね
準備するものがあるみたいです
ぬいぐるみ、手と足があるもの
米、あと縫う用の針
赤い糸
刃物とか鋭利なもの
塩水
避難所を作る
家の中に避難所を作るべきらしいです
あとはお線香
え、こわいよ・・・
えぇ－・・・
たぶん霊感ないから何も感じないとは思うんですけど
結構書いてあることが怖いな
えぇーとやり方を言います
ぬいぐるみの綿を全て抜き、代わりに米を詰めます
米は本来は内臓を表すみたいで、えっと霊を集める役割をするみたいです
その２
自分の爪を切り、詰めのかけらをぬいぐるみの中に入れ、詰めて、穴を赤い糸で縫うと。
縫い終わったらそのまま糸をぬいぐるみに巻付け、ある程度巻いたらくくる
風呂桶に水を張ります
で、最後に隠れる場所に塩水を用意しておく
ここまでが準備になると
実際にやり方の説明です
ぬいぐるみに名前を付ける
そのあと、午前３時になったら
最初の鬼ははじめだから
と、ぬいぐるみに向かって３回言う
万が一の時のために出入り口の鍵を開けておきすぐ駆けつけてきてくれる友人等を用意しておくのがベスト！…
怖いな
びんびん、もうビンビンに怖いんですけど
ひとりかくれんぼは途中で終わることは絶対にやめてください
かならず最後までやり遂げること
これさー怖いんだけど
結構がっつりじゃないですか
やり方は一通りわかったのでやってみますか
わりとね僕も何回もやろうと思ったんですけど、怖くて手が出せなかったんですけど…
怖い目にあっちゃったくらいの方がいいかと思って
実際にちょっとやっていきましょう
時刻が今２時４２分、あと１８分後で３時でございます
ひとりかくれんぼするのは一人じゃなくてもいいらしいです
僕はとっても怖いので生贄に後輩二人を準備しました
よろしくお願いします
後輩たち：お願いします
まずどうなっても俺は責任とらないからね…
霊感は…ないんでしょ？
後輩１：ないです…
後輩２：笑笑
あるんでしょ？
後輩２：ちょっとだけ…
そっかぁ…
人の形をしてるものならなんでも良さそうなのでこれを使います
持ち物はここらへんで全部揃いました
では早速準備に移りましょう
後輩：ぬいぐるみの綿を抜いて…？　　はじめ：とりあえず米を詰める！
後輩：米を詰める…
後輩：これ俺らも全員でやるんですか？
はじめ：そうだよ！　後輩：え！！
参加者全員に鬼の役が回るようにかくれんぼする
ははwガチじゃん
後輩：いやいやいや...
俺がぁ例えば...参加者全員に鬼の役が回るようかくれんぼにしますー、
うわ鳥肌よ...多分そういうことだと思う
はじめ：やろう.. 　　後輩：やろう...やるしかねぇ...　　はじめ：うんやるしかない...
じゃあ全員分のツメ入れなきゃ...こわっ！！
はじめ：終わったら遊戯王しよう
綿を抜いたのでこの中に米を詰めます
はじめ：どうしよういやんなっちゃてきた...
はじめ：何て顔してるの...なにそれ？？汗　後輩：いやいや...
ねぇ待って、どうしたの？汗 大丈夫？笑
後輩２：これなんなんすかそもそも...
霊を呼ぶ儀式らしい
降霊術の一つ...
後輩２：あぁーーー待ってその..
後輩２：霊が...呼ぶって霊になんかされますか、その霊に
いや特にそういう記述はない
後輩２：えー待って本当に大丈夫かな
後輩２：俺さ、それ、ちょっとよしたほうがいいかも...
マジで言ってる？
後輩２：...えっと,ちょっと言いたくないけど、
後輩２：やべ涙出てきちゃった
え！！
このメンツ？！
~怖い音楽~
マジで怖くてそれで起きちゃって...
実家に行ってておばあに『なんでお前そんなに冷や汗かいてるん？』って
後輩1:ええ...怖！！  はじめ:どうしよっか
ちょっとやめとくか
後輩２：えええ..待って
後輩２：正夢になんないよね？ 後輩１&はじめ：なんないよ...
後輩２：人まで当たる…？
本当にこのメンツだったの？？　後輩２：本当にこのメンツです
後輩２：ふるえとまんないよ
やめとこう！！！　すみません、今回はやめておきます
いや、そこまで言うならちょっと止めておいたほうがいいかもね
でも後輩を守るのが先輩の役目だからね！　　　　　　後輩：笑笑
こういうことするキャラじゃないんですよ
はじめ：なんで泣き出した？！　後輩１：びっくりした...
後輩２：え...だって..本当に..だって
後輩２：わかりやすい..
後輩２：夢見てそれが…
はじめ：俺が突発的に言い出したからね、今日
はじめ：赤い糸買ってて言う意味も…
後輩２：そう、全然わかんなかった！　後輩１：本当に？？
後輩２：手芸道具かなんかと思った
後輩２：ああああもうやばい！！
後輩２：なんだろこれめっちゃ暑い！！
違うよなぁ本当に
後輩２：あああ焦ったぁ
はじめ:そんなに...!
はじめ:まぁでもなんかさ夢で見たのがさー
はじめ：実際にやってみてまさかこういう内容だったっていうのが怖いよね
後輩：確かに
後輩２：本当に焦った
はじめ：その怖い人って女の人なの？
後輩２：普通の人。本当に
はじめ：太ってる？
後輩２：全然
後輩２：あ、身長高い
はじめ：高い？　後輩１：もっと怖いな
はじめ:誰だ…
後輩２：ああ！ダメだ！思い出したくない本当に(泣)　涙出てくる...
後輩２：なんだろこの涙
はじめ：遊戯王しよう
はじめ:…ええ、なんかこれトイレにも行きたくない　後輩：やばいめっちゃ出てくるよー泣
後輩２：でももう一人いた気がする
はじめ:だいすけじゃないの？？
後輩２：だいすけじゃない
はじめ：あぁでも夢ってさー思い出せないじゃん！誰が誰とか…
後輩：そうですね
後輩２：男だった気がするんだよなぁ　はじめ：…男…とも？
後輩１：ともゆきじゃない？　後輩２：あ、ともゆきかも
はじめ：ええ！
後輩１：来るかもしんないって言ってたじゃん
はじめ：今日？！こわ！！！！
はじめ：完全にそのメンツじゃん
はじめ：ましてやさ、もし俺たちがやってたとするじゃん、仮に、今日
後輩：そう…きちゃったら…　はじめ：帰ってたら終わりでしょ。もうそこで
うわ怖！！！